hi Sandra it's barry silbert of the
founder of CEO probably called
SecondMarket so I guess the question is
what we're doing to support innovation
what second work is done is actually
created a market place to allow private
companies to trade their shares there's
I think a lot of discussion about
whether or not the public markets are
broken I think they are and so we're
trying to do is create a new better
market structure to allow small
companies to raise capital to allow
small companies to to grow to the point
where they actually could go home work
it's really important to kind of get
this capital flowing the system because
at the end of the day small businesses
are the ones that actually kind of
create the jobs so the ones that
innovates they're the ones that are
going to I think i'ma go forward base is
going to change the world and so we want
to do everything we can a second market
to support the efforts of entrepreneurs
around the world to crease innovation
get the capital flowing
Oh